[Captions by Y Translator]
Hey everyone, we've got a lot going on
behind the scenes here
at the King of Random and we
want to keep you in the loop.
So, if you are interested
in being the first to know
about exclusive news and offers, go ahead
and click the link in the description
and sign up for our mailing list.
A while ago, we used some kinetic sand
and some molten gallium to cast
a small version of Grants face.
Today, we wanted to scale that up
and we're going to be trying
to make a life-size cast
of my face in metal.
This kinetic sand stuff is really cool
and it compresses down holding
a surprising amount of detail,
which is why before, we
took this little 3D print of Grants face,
used it to make a mold and then
cast some gallium into that sand.
That worked out really well.
And today, we want
to try scaling that up.
We've got quite a bit more kinetic sand,
and we're going to see
if we can do a full size
casting of my face.
What we're going
for here is pretty simple.
We're going to take
a bunch of kinetic sand,
put it into a box,
and then try smushing my face
into the sand to make a mold,
filling it with molten gallium,
which should cool off
into a solid metal face.
So we've got kinetic sand here,
here, here, and here.
And then we've got a bunch of gallium
and this stuff is super cool,
by which I mean, it's molten
while it's quite cool.
I can easily put my hand in it
without any worry of burning
because it's just not that hot.
Our thermometer's actually
currently registering the surface
as below the freezing point of gallium,
which means it should be solidifying
and it is a little bit we've got sort
of a skin on here.
This gallium is currently just
barely warm enough to stay liquid.
It's cooling down fairly quickly
and we start getting solid parts
and this can easily
remelt including just...
By putting it down
at the bottom of this
but it is cooling
off quite a bit.
When it's hot, it stays bright
and silvery a lot quicker,
but this is cool,
so as I clear a space away
it just starts freezing,
and you can see it stopped being
quite so silvery very quickly.
So, the goal is going to be to take
our kinetic sand, put that into a box,
and try and smush my face
into it well enough
that we can cast it in gallium.
But I do have a couple
other things I want to try.
I have a bunch of colored sand
and I actually just want
to see what it looks like
pouring the molten gallium
into that colored sand,
so I'm going to do
a few experiments with that too.
[Music]
The sand is so much lighter weight
that it's actually just floating on top.
[Music]
Gallium pours into sand
fairly interestingly,
the sand sort of floats on top of it.
We've seen that it does not behave
the same way with kinetic sand,
especially if we smash it down.
So let's take all
of our kinetic sand,
put it in this box and see
if I can make a mold of my face.
[Music]
I've got two methods that
we're going to try.
First, I'm going to see what happens
if I actually just smush my face down
into this sand.
I'll hold my breath,
keep my eyes closed,
and press my face down in,
see what sort of indentation I can get.
Now, the sand
has some good give to it
but so does my face,
so do all faces.
So, I'm afraid that may
or may not work out too well,
but I do have a plan B.
But let's try this,
take off my glasses,
got a towel for when I pull my face out
so I can just wipe it all off.
Things I do for you guys.
[Music]
It's like if I were turned
into Voldemort...
And Voldemort had a beard.
You can see all my facial hair,
it picked up all the details-- Like,
my whole face is so smashed flat.
So, smushing my face down
into this sand gave an impression
of an extremely smushed face.
That's not quite what we're going for,
entertaining as that is to look at.
Uh, so we do have a plan B.
Several years ago,
helping out in a friend's makeup class,
I had this made.
This is actually a copy of my face,
if my face had no hair on top,
no eyebrows, no facial hair, nothing.
But that's me right there.
[Music]
This is made of...
What I believe is called Ultracal,
it's sort of a cross
between plaster and cement.
It's really really hard,
much harder than my face
and much harder than the kinetic sand.
And so, if we press this down
into the kinetic sand,
we should just get a nice imprint
without any deformation.
We're going to do that now.
We're going to get the sand
back to being fluffy
and then we're going
to set this up
so we can tip it down and just
smush it down into the sand
and hopefully get a nice,
clean, unsmashed version
of my face in the kinetic sand.
[Music]
We've got the face
smushed in pretty good,
and I'm just trying to smush down
all the rest of the sand,
so it's properly reinforced
and will hold its shape.
That's all right.
I'm just gonna kind of...
Grab me by my ears here and...
[Music]
We have my face smushed
into the sand, and in theory,
my current actual face should
fit nicely down into that,
and I'm going to see if it does.
[Music]
That fits quite nicely.
I guess I shouldn't really be surprised,
it's my face after all,
but like it-- It
goes down in and...
I can just feel it lightly touching
all parts of my face and maybe
getting pink sand on it,
I don't know about that.
But now, we're going to round up all
of the gallium that we have
and slowly carefully
pour it in there.
That way we'll have
a metal cast of my face.
[Music]
Random fact, kinetic sand is made
out of 98 percent regular sand
and 2% Polydimethylsiloxane,
an important component of silly putty.
That is as full
as we can get it.
Okay guys, my face has now
been poured in gallium,
and we need to let this cool down,
and that actually takes quite a while.
The gallium, when it's
in a liquid state likes
to hold on to it for a while.
And so, it's going to take some time
for this to all freeze back into a solid block.
Once it is, we can pull it
out of the sand and see
if we have a metal cast of my face.
Okay, I think it's time
for the main event.
Let's try pulling
this face out.
[Music]
Our sand's sticking to it,
but I think we've got something
face-like showing up.
[Music]
Well, I... Think that
worked out pretty nicely.
Now, it's a little bit hard to see
the similarities when you're just looking
at an all one color face
that doesn't have the rest
of the head or hair on it.
But, I think that did
a really good job
and you can see pretty
much just the same shape.
[Music]
Now I have my lovely
metal face to go along
with my lovely concrete face,
and my okay skin made face.
I want to see if I can't polish
this up just a little bit
so we can have like
a shiny metal look.
[Music]
Casting my face in kinetic sand,
that actually worked really well.
Of course, we had to use
my stone-like face to really get the mold
because I was getting a very smushed look
when I just press my face down
into the kinetic sand.
Although, that was
pretty fun too.
But overall, I think
we had a great result.
I don't know what I'm going to do
with a metal face of myself,
but it's pretty neat.
This kinetic sand works really
well for casting gallium.
Gallium melts at such a low temperature
like 85 degrees Fahrenheit,
that it doesn't burn
the kinetic sand the way
like molten aluminum does.
There may be some other things
that will cast really well
in kinetic sand too.
We'd love to hear your ideas
of what you'd like to see us try.
It is still a granule sand,
so we don't want to do things
that are too liquid.
I suspect most types of resin
would just seep right down
through the sand,
but maybe if we
compact it enough that wouldn't happen.
We also made some time aside
to show you how to make one
of these things for yourself.
We've already got
a stone cast Nate.
Maybe we'll make
a stone cast Grant.
Guys, thanks for watching.
But that's not all, that box up
at the top will transport you
directly to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you aren't a subscriber yet,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.